forget the US election the truly
important question is do you support the
billionaire narcissist or the humorless
authoritarian I am of course talking
about Iron Man and Captain America
obviously I'm Kate and this is your
GameSpot news updates
this is shaping up to be the year of the
superhero face-off
Batman will fight Superman later this
month while Marvel heroes Captain
America and Iron Man will come to blows
in May when Captain America Civil War
hits cinemas now a new batch of images
has been released by Marvel Captain
America Civil War is directed by Joe and
Anthony Russo and stars Chris Evans
Robert Downey jr. Anthony Mackie
Scarlett Johansson and Jeremy Renner it
focuses on the conflict between Captain
America and Iron Man following attempts
to regulate superhero activity in a
recent Q&A at the Wizard World Cleveland
comic-con Joe Russo spoke about how this
latest film would differ from his
previous Marvel movie 2014's Captain
America the Winter Soldier we really did
a radical reinterpretation of Captain
America in Winter Soldier he said by
Cleveland calm we were twice as
aggressive in tone and execution on
civil war last week it was revealed that
Hobbit star Martin Freeman would play
government agent Everett Ross in the
upcoming movie Ross is a character
primarily associated with Black Panther
who will be making his Marvel Universe
debut in Civil War played by chadwick
boseman do you think Civil War will be
any good let me know in the comments or
come and find me on twitter i'm at how
not to draw thanks for watching and fro
you're gaming and entertainment news
keep it GameSpot